Check out this trade right here. This is
exactly what I'm going to teach you how
to do this morning. How you can show up
every day in the market, trade for just
30 to 60 minutes in the morning, and
find clean, consistent, profitable
setups like this that have allowed me to
make thousands when I enter into them.
We're going to go through a complete
scalping road map that'll teach you a
foundation of how to read the market,
mistakes to avoid, what to actually
enter in on, and what is a good signal
and when to trade, and then how to
manage. And we'll go through a couple of
clean examples at the end where I show
you the multi-step entry checklist I use
every single trade to either enter into
a trade or avoid entering the trade that
allows me to know [music] when it's
actually good. and worthwhile taking a
trade. Okay, so first off, some basics
about scalping. Scalping the whole idea
is you are taking small trades on a
small time frame chart. I enter in
trades on generally a one minute chart
and I'm essentially looking for just
capturing like a move from here to here.
I'm not looking for a massive swing in
the market. If we zoom all the way out,
I'm not looking for a huge move over
multiple days. you're going into a small
time frame chart and looking for a quick
[music]
move to happen. The trades are generally
really short in length. You can see
here, this one I entered in on about,
you know, 7 46 my time, and I ended up
getting out about here, which was
[music] 7:48. So, it literally took me
like 10 or 15 minutes. They're very
fast. Sometimes they can be long just if
depending on the market, but generally
if there's good movement, you're going
to be in and out of a trade very
quickly. But the whole idea of this
[music] is think about yourself as like
a sniper in the army. You are sitting
there patiently waiting for the perfect
shot or trade setup to happen. I took
this trade this morning and I haven't
taken a trade all week. I haven't taken
a trade. If we zoom out to a larger time
frame chart, here's 1 day, 2 day, 3day,
4 day. It's currently Thursday. I didn't
take a trade this day, this day, or this
day. And so, it's a lot of waiting. But
the idea is you're waiting for that
perfect setup or almost perfect setup to
happen. And then when you jump in, you
can make a lot of money once you
sidestep. A lot of mistakes that people
do and that I did a lot when I first
started out too is trying to capture
every move is trying to capture this
move and then capture this move. And
it's impossible to capture every single
move in the market. Instead, I found it
to be way more consistently profitable
is to wait something like all week for a
really clean setup. And then the money
you make comes from sizing up. It's easy
to get stuck in that trap of, "Oh, well,
if I make a $100 every trade, well, to
make $1,000 this week, I need to make 10
trades." And [music] taking 10
profitable trades without any losers is
really hard to do. Trading is really
hard at the end of the day. And so, I
find it way easier to be super patient
during the whole week. And once a, you
know, in a way a perfect setup shows up,
that's when you can jump in because a
lot of the time if you look at it, you
know, the rest of the day once this move
happened, the market's just choppy and
it's really hard to trade. There is
movement in here that you could
theoretically make money off of, but
that's really hard to do consistently
over time. Another big issue that I had
in the beginning was going for a small
amount of money with my trades is going
for, let's say, $50 and I'm risking
$100. What this does is it gives you a
negative riskreward ratio. And so what
you want to do is flip that. And so I
found it to be way more consistently
profitable to have something like a 1:2
or 1:3 riskreward ratio where I'm
risking let's say $100 to make 200 or
300. And so I find that extremely
important to do. A mistake I did that I
highly recommend you not doing. Trading
when you first start out, you really
want to jump in and make a lot of money,
but that comes with time. Instead, focus
on the patterns and consistently trying
to execute something over time. The
process is the most important part. It
takes a long time to get to the size I
am at and to be able to make an actual
lot of money from trading. So now let's
jump into how to analyze and read the
price movement of the charts. Because
[music] if you look at my charts, this
is my chart from this morning. Literally
all I look at is the swings of the
market. I make some support levels
there. um this morning had, you know, a
downtrend level I was watching for a
little while. And sometimes I'll use one
indicator that we'll go over in a bit
too to help me identify when there's
movement potential as well. But really,
learning to just read the charts and
look at the swings has helped me
tremendously in clarity in the market.
And so the basics is literally just
reading it as the big picture swings.
don't get bogged down in what every
individual candlestick is doing. I only
start to really focus on that at the
last moment when I'm about to enter into
a trade. Instead, what I really look at
is, okay, what are the swings doing?
What do they look like? And so some
basics and we'll get over to some more
complex ways and advanced ways to read
in a minute, but some basics is a
downtrend like this is literally just
signified by making lower highs and
consistently lower lows. And that just
shows me that we are in a downtrend. And
then once that breaks [music] and it
starts to make an uptrend where it now
makes an higher high and then if I
scroll this to the side, it could start
to show, okay, that downtrend has
changed and we're going to shift. And in
this case, it started to go into a
sideways trend where the lows and the
highs are pretty much the same. And then
at that point now it looks like okay
maybe we're going to stay in this
sideways trend or it could eventually
find some support here and start an
actual uptrend where in an uptrend it's
signified by making higher highs and
higher lows. That is it's super simple
but the way I became actually profitable
trading was almost dumb it down to where
it's almost seems silly with how simple
it is. But the reason why this works is
because trading is so complicated and
there's so many ways that you can read
the market. There's so many indicators
you can use. And what simplifying it
does is it takes a lot of that out and
it makes your decision making very
simple. What actually makes people and
why you know 95% of people aren't
profitable trading is it's because their
decisionm [music] isn't consistent
because they're reading so many
different things. There's so many
different variables to juggle. It's
really hard to stick to your strategy
and execute it over time. And so that's
what I found to be very very simple and
helpful with consistently trading and
becoming profitable over time. And so
the next thing is that can help me with
a downtrend that I like to use is a
trend line. Essentially, all I'm looking
for is when you see when you come into
the market and see a trend. I pretty
much opened my charts this morning and
it looked like this. And so I'm saying,
okay, there's a trend line here
somewhere. You know, I like to match it
from a extreme high if possible and then
make a second touch here. But you can
see after a couple of other swings, it
clearly wasn't following that trend. And
so instead, I looked at, okay, well,
what about this one here? This one
didn't really touch here, but it
eventually touched pretty well here. And
so that's a clean trend that the
market's in. And so when it eventually
breaks that, I see that okay, well, the
trend could be shifting. And it doesn't
mean that it's not it's immediately as
soon as a trend line is broken that it's
just going to reverse right away. That's
totally not true. It just shows you that
this current trend that the market's in
is shifting. And what that could mean is
it's shifting into a sideways trend,
shifting into an uptrend, or the
downtrend gets more extreme. But
generally, this is kind of an advanced
tip, is that when a trend line like this
breaks and the market goes more extreme,
is that it's a final push lower where
the market here actually kind of gets
exhausted. And that's what helped me
realize that we could have a big
snapback this morning. How I helped to
enter into my trade this morning.
Another really useful tool, if I jump
out to a larger time frame chart here,
is a channel as well. I don't use these
as often because they're not as
consistent in sticking to how the market
is reacting, but if you look at this
market here, you can see there's a high
here, a high here, which is what I drew
the line off of, and then it actually
hits this one pretty well as well. And
then what you do is you draw it down to
the lows, and you can start to see,
okay, here it bounced. And you can kind
of adjust this too to where well maybe
this fits a little bit better and it
just kind of broke out here a little
bit. And [music]
when you're drawing them, don't feel
like you need to be exact and it needs
to be an exact science. And if it breaks
it slightly, okay, it's broken.
Sometimes it can have it just a little
spike out and then it breaks. But
instead, what I find the best way to do
this is when it breaks, it's clearly
clearly broken. And so if I just extend
this a little bit more up here because
it did eventually break here is that
once it's broken, then I'm going to
consider again that the trend is
shifting and that we could go into
either a sideways trend or start a
downtrend. And so there's a couple ways
to identify which direction it's going
to go that we'll talk about in a minute.
The last big key I want to talk about
here is sideways horizontal res support
and resistance. I didn't actually see
this a lot when I started is I saw a lot
of times people would just draw a
specific line and if it broke you know
it broke and so again trying not to be
super precise is just drawing it off of
like this swing, this swing and this
swing and thinking of it as a zone. you
know, this is where the market is
likely, if it comes up in this area, is
likely to find resistance and get pushed
back lower. That's a lot better way to
treat a support and resistance zone and
also um a a potential uptrend is where
the market will bounce somewhere near
this area because again, the market
isn't super precise like that. And so
what you could do off of drawing the
zone here once the market came up here,
you could say, okay, well, we're in this
area and it's likely I can look for a
potential reversal off of this. And so,
you know, you can see here it broke out
slightly, but a lot of times what I see,
and this is another kind of advanced
thing that took me a while to realize,
is that the market will have, and this
is an even stronger signal, is what I
like to call a failed breakout where it
essentially breaks the previous high.
And this is actually into all-time highs
on the S&P 500 futures here that it will
end up reversing like this. The idea
with this is once it breaks the new
high, a lot of breakout traders will
think, okay, well, it's broken the
previous high, that's a good signal to
go long. And so they'll buy here and
instead the market flips on them and
this starts a cascading effect of
trapping those traders. And so the
market has to it helps push the momentum
even more to the downside. So you can
see here we got a huge flush off of that
and a lot of volatility. And so this is
how I like to pay attention to those
[music] levels. And I've actually got a
video that goes way more in depth into
drawing support and resistance levels
that I'll just put in a card up here
that you can watch after this video. I
highly recommend it. It'll go into, you
know, the five key steps on drawing
support and resistance, how to read them
properly. And so let's go into some
signals of how to know, you know, when a
market is going to come up and hit a
level like this and reverse versus
continuing higher. It's really helpful
to be able to identify all these levels.
It, you know, it's not rocket science,
right? It's easy to look at a chart and
to see, okay, I got one, I got two, I
got three touches, I'll draw this zone,
but then when it comes down to it, how
do you know or make a good educated
guess? because you you know nothing in
the market is certain. But how do you
make a good educated guess to take a
trade off of somewhere and actually
enter in on something that you can
consistently profit from? That's the
hardest part about trading and reading
the markets. And so again, going back to
kind of the basics, if we just analyze
the swing right here, just based off the
swings, it makes a high here, a low, a
higher high, and then it starts to it
makes a lower low here. And then as well
it makes a lower high. And so based on
this reading is we were in an uptrend
here. It didn't really have many
pullbacks. You know, you could consider
there's little pullbacks here in the
swing, but on this one minute chart, it
looks like it's just going parabolic.
And that's okay. But when you're reading
this is looking at the swings. And so a
huge signal I use constantly and this is
even for just entering into trades that
we'll really talk about later is once
this high here gets put in and then this
lower low gets put in. I'm starting to
that puts alarm bells off in my brain of
okay well if it puts in a lower high
here I think it's very likely that you
know we start to go in that downtrend
where it makes lower more consistent
lower lows and more consistent lower
highs and so that's the very basic just
reading the structure of the market way
that you can you know I suggest just
going into a chart and just looking at
what that looks like you know looking at
different charts where you have
consistent and higher highs here and
then it starts to make a lower high here
and a lower low and a lower high and
then boom, all of a sudden you get this
massive start of a trend. And so there's
signals here that you can start to see
before this huge move happens. And so
you could use that signal to jump in
here and capture this whole move lower.
And the second part about that is you
want to be combining these with other
things. I don't just go into, you know,
I'm I'm I'm teaching this in hindsight,
but I don't go into a market and take a
trade. I wouldn't take a trade just
right here based on just that. It has to
have other things [music] align. And so,
if we just look at, you know, further
back in the chart, you can see there's
kind of these larger swings, right? And
so, thinking about, okay, well, every
time the market seems to come up here,
here, here, here, and here, well, we've
reversed off of that, right? And so what
would that do is that would make me want
to draw a resistance zone based off of
all of these swings. And so when the
market comes up here again somewhere in
this zone, I'm going to think, okay, the
likelihood of it reversing now has
higher probability. And so that coupled
with looking at just the swings here
increases that likelihood of okay, well,
we've hit this level now and now we're
starting to make lower highs here and
lower lows. Well, that actually gives me
more concrete evidence that yes, we
could get a selloff. Now, I don't know
what the sell-off would look like, but
that's where you would actually enter in
a trade. And you know, maybe I would put
my stop up here based off of this swing.
We'll get into that more in a bit. And
so that's how you can start to build a
reading of the market based on the
structure. Some other big signals here I
find just based off this trade I had
this morning is look at this. So this
the market right here has been in a
massive uptrend. And so it's been really
hard to trade. I haven't found any good
trades because of that, which is totally
fine. I did a great job of sticking to
my strategy. It was kind of hard because
you're just sitting there and waiting.
But that's a part of good trading. not
going to be, you know, going in and
making thousands a day. You have to
patiently wait for when things align.
And so, but what I saw going into this
morning was there was this gap up we had
where the market closed here and then
made a huge jump. That is a big area of
interest and why I made a support zone
there. And then going into today, well,
we came down and bounced off of that
support zone. And so it doesn't
necessarily need to be multiple swings
in an area. There can be other factors
of either a high of a gap up like this
down here at the low of this gap up
where the gap up started. The market
essentially closed and then gapped up.
This would be another spot I would think
about if the [music] market continued to
sell off. And other key areas are as
well is where the market closed
yesterday. If I scroll back, here's a
one minute chart. And on my system, it
has this line right here where that
market closes. And you can see there was
actually a little bit of a gap here.
Now, it filled that. So, I'm not really
concerned about the gap. I would want to
then draw a zone here just to keep in
mind, okay, this is where the market
closed and opened, and this is a point
of interest. And so, you can see the
market actually bounced off of this area
multiple times overnight. And then going
into today, you can actually see that's
pretty much where we came up and bounced
off of multiple times today as well. And
so that's a huge key of other areas of
interests to draw zones. And then the
other one is for me, the market opens up
at 7:30 here. And so I would want to
draw a zone at the market open today.
And so you can see if we pull that
across, once we broke above this, it
came down and bounced off of there
multiple times. Those are pretty much
the main keys I look for when I'm
finding zones is the market open, the
market close, and then just key areas of
swings in the overnight and previous
days action. And then of course, like I
just had before, this doesn't happen
often, but potential gaps, huge gap ups
in the market or gaps down. I generally
don't look back more than you know four
or five days and generally the day
before is the strongest area to be
looking at because the most recent
levels are the most important [music]
and just with this knowledge you can
understand so much about the market and
some big keys I want you to think about
now that we'll get into a couple of of
advanced things is look at the
candlesticks here look at how these ones
Look, this move up essentially looks
compared to this one right here. You
know, they're about the same length.
This one's definitely larger, but look
at what the candlesticks look like. This
one, the candlesticks are just very
bullish. The market's moving in one
direction pretty much very clearly.
There's some pullbacks here and some
more choppyish candles, [music] but it's
very fast movement compared to this
swing right here. there's a lot of more
candlesticks on top of each other from,
you know, here the price doesn't move
from here to here over these, you know,
four or five candlesticks. And so what
that shows you is there's a lot more
choppiness. And so this is a huge thing
that I look into and look at every day
when I'm trading. This is great
movement, but as soon as the market
starts to look like this, that's when
you know that, okay, the volatility has
essentially dried up and it's going to
be way harder to enter into a trade. How
I find good trades and consistent
profitability is waiting for when
there's good movement like this. And on
these days, if I if I literally just
scroll back to yesterday, you can see
here the market opened up here. Here's
7:30 and here's 8. That same window of
trading I had this morning is look at
how choppy this movement is. [music] You
know, we had a little bit of a spike
here uh and and a little bit of a move
here, but if you look at other than
that, it's insanely choppy that the
candlesticks are all over each other.
And [music] you know, comparing that to
this move this morning where there was a
nice move and even the movement before,
there was still good movement and
direction going on. And so that's how
you can really tell when it's good to
take a trade and when it's not. You want
to avoid choppy markets and you want to
trade in volatile ones. If we go back
actually if you look at even the price
moving over here is this move this
morning right here from let's say just
the lows to the highs was about 40
points in ES futures and if I go to
yesterday the market open this move to
this move right here was about 20 points
if that it was more like 15 and so it's
moving a lot less even though it looks
like on your screen it's it's zoomed in
and fit it's moving a lot less. And so,
be aware of what kind of movement the
market is having back and forth
throughout the day because this will
really help you know, okay, today is a
day I really need to pay attention to
and today is a day where, you know,
there's probably going to be not much
going on. Another quick advanced tip
here is when the market is in a nice
downtrend, methodical downtrend like
this, when all of a sudden it starts to
accelerate like this and you have it
essentially, you know, there's not a
great trend line here, but you could
say, you know, maybe it's in some kind
of downtrend like this, right? It didn't
fit in a nice perfect downtrend line,
but it's still, you can see it's in a
consistent downtrend. And so because of
that, well, it started to accelerate
here. And when the market starts to
really accelerate in one direction, it's
getting overextended. What I like to
call it is it's an unhealthy move. And
an unhealthy move in the market actually
gets reversed a lot of the time. In a
healthy move and market, there are moves
down with pullbacks and it makes it so
it never really gets overextended. And
when it does and it gets overextended,
it has to have some kind of pullback.
But a lot of the time because if
especially like right here, this
overextension is already after a big
move down. Well, a lot of people that
have caught this move are going to close
out for a profit. And then at this
point, well, it could be getting to a
support zone where a lot of buyers are
going to start stepping [music] in. And
so all of this is putting buying
pressure on this and it can have a
larger move here and a snap. And what
this causes a lot of the time is it will
cause the downtrend to end and it will
cause either a move up to start
happening or just, you know, at the end
of the day the trend is going to shift.
And so this is a huge signal that I like
to use for the trend reversing and a
really helpful indicator to use. If I go
to a five-minute chart, I like to use
this is it's called a fair value gap
indicator. Essentially what it does is
it just puts you can generally get this
for free on any platform, but what it
does is it essentially shows you when
there is a move. If we just zoom in
quickly on this area is where you look
at this candlestick is it moves the
price moves up very quickly and then it
continues to move up. And so essentially
it marks easily unhealthy moves in the
market where it needs essentially a
pullback to create that healthiness
again. [music] And so you can see here
we had an unhealthy move here and the
market eventually pulled back and filled
that essentially that gap that is made.
And then on the flip side, it had the
same thing here where it had a huge
unhealthy move. We had the indicator
popping off here with these boxes and
then we had to have pullbacks into that
area. Now, it doesn't necessarily mean
it's going to fill the box perfectly,
but that's consistently what happens.
And so this morning, even this trade I
caught that went down here, there was
signals of this, even these small
signals here. Well, if you go into a one
minute chart, that helped snap this
back. And then I had other factors in
there as well that we'll go over in a
minute. Okay. So, what I want to do now
is go through my trade entry checklist
for you in a very structured way so you
can then know exactly what I'm looking
for. And then we can go into some real
examples so you can see what it's like
in real time because on paper it's a lot
different than when you're actually
looking at a chart, you know, because at
the end of the day, you know, the charts
are all over the place. No trade looks
the exact same. And so the hard part is
to be able to, you know, take something
like a simple entry checklist and
consistently
use that same thing for every trade. And
so the whole idea behind my strategy and
what really helped me simplify things is
I literally only look for reversal
trades. I only look for spots where I
think the market is going to reverse. I
look for a trend to move into that
level. I look for a couple steps we're
about to go through. And then I look to
enter in and take a short off of that
level and capture a move down that the
market has generally in the first 50 to
30 minutes in the morning. And so the
first thing that needs to happen for
that is drawing and marking off those
key support and resistance zones. And
generally I do that from a 15 or 30
minute chart. Most of the time it's from
a 15-inute chart. And then for those
zones, I like to have, you know, at
least two major swings. Again, make sure
to check out that other video with those
key steps, but I went through a lot of
them in this one already. And it's
important to stick to the extremes of
those zones and levels. That other video
will go a lot more through that, but so
step one is needing that big picture
reversal zone. It's not worth it to
[music] get bogged down in all the
little moves that the market's having.
Stick to the extremes because at the
extremes, you're more likely to have a
larger snap and a clean move that's easy
to profit from. Now, step two is the
second big key. And so, these go [music]
in priority of importance. Step one is
the most important thing. If you don't
have a clean zone to reverse off of,
there's no trade. [music] Step two is
analyzing that trend. If it's not clear
and you don't have a good understanding
of the trend, do not take the trade. I
have taken so many trades where I wasn't
quite sure and they always end up
losing. It's hard to be patient, but
entering in a trade only when you're the
most confident is going to increase your
profitability a lot. And so I generally
enter in on a one minute chart,
sometimes a five-minute chart, but I
really have been sticking to a one
minute chart these days. Simpler is
always better. [music] There needs to be
a clear trend shift. A lot of what that
means is just some of those basics we
were talking about is there's a
downtrend and you know it's clearly
broken and there's you know it's
starting to make higher highs and higher
lows. Another thing, it's not
complicated, but again, it's extremely
[music] important. It needs to be clear
that there is something like a big
flush, the trend is clearly starting to
either reverse or it's overextended and
likely to have a volatile snapback.
Those need to be in place. I've taken
trades sometimes where, you know, I if
we cut that out here and you look at
this right here where the market was
having a downtrend right here and it's
starting to slow down and it looks like
this is making a higher high here and a
higher low. But if you jump in a trade
too early without enough confirmation or
without a nice snap like this where it
really shows the overextension of the
market, well, you would have jumped in a
trade here betting [music] to the upside
and it would have knocked you out a
loss. And that's the hard part about
trading is waiting for that really solid
confirmation. And so step three, we
haven't really gone over this stuff as
much. So this is a lot of the really
important part of okay when do you
finally confirm of when to enter and
when you know what are the final
confirmations and so what we've been
doing a lot of the time is looking at
the big picture now how do we look at
the smaller picture and some of the
micro patterns [music] and actually know
when to enter and so you know kind of a
huge important part of step three here
is like we talked about no choppiness
[music]
in the market you do not want to be
entering in when the market is like
this. Now on this day there is a little
bit more volatility but you know again
if I go back to the day before extreme
choppiness do not enter in that it's
hard to be patient but you have to learn
to do that. If you can't learn to be
patient you're not going to be a
consistently profitable trader. I can
guarantee it. Now, some of the clean,
consistent patterns I like to look for
are either, you know, a double bottom
and just buying right there as it breaks
the high because this double bottom is
nice confirmation. The market has
essentially right here with the double
bottom. That's to me showing that the
market is if it's in a downtrend, it's
going to make a new low. But if it makes
a double bottom and starts to make a new
high, that's a good enough confirmation
that the micro trend is starting to
shift. Again, remember this is stacking
on top of that. It's already at a clear
support zone and the bigger picture is
aligning that it's in an area that it's
going to reverse. Another huge pattern I
like [music] is actually a head and
shoulders pattern. And really all this
pattern is if you look at it is it's
just the basics of the swings of showing
you that oh it's now making it's from
going from higher highs and higher lows
to making uh you know a lower low and a
lower high and that's a good signal that
it's going to start going down. Now the
reality of this can look a little
different. Sometimes it's not going to
perfectly make a double bottom here.
It'll sometimes make a higher low and
then a lower low. That's actually
generally a better signal. If this low
breaks this low, it's just sooner
showing you that it's there's weakness
in the market. Really, that's all these
swings are telling you is, okay, if it
can't make a new high here, that's
weakness. If it makes a new low here and
breaks this previous one, that's
weakness. If this low here starts to
sell off sooner, that's weakness. And
that's what you want if you're betting
that the market's going to go lower. And
on the flip side, it's the exact same
thing. And there's some other key
patterns here I won't go over right now,
but this sheet is part of a free 14page
PDF guide with a ton of these different
patterns and kind of key importances to
the pattern that you can download for
free. I'll leave a QR code on the screen
or a link in the description of this
video that you can find it at. Now, the
next last thing here is the candlestick
confirmation. This is basically, okay, I
am about to enter into the trade. This
is the last signal that I need to look
for. And this is now you're starting to
dive into the actual candlesticks.
You're [music] getting smaller and
smaller as you go through this
checklist. And what I like to see, these
are some three patterns that I like to
see. Either um really strong candlestick
[music] strength in the reversal
direction. I'm looking for an engulfing
candlestick pattern or a threeline
strike pattern. And so the threeline
strike pattern is essentially if you're
in an uptrend here is basically it's
showing you there's strength, strength,
and then all of a sudden there's a
massive move. And so what this massive
move tells you is that it's hit that
point where you know all these other
things are stacking. This is essentially
think of this swing right here as the
lower high in your head and shoulders
pattern. And so what this is showing you
is okay there is a a lot of bearishness
and strength to the downside as this
lower high is forming of the head larger
head and shoulders picture. [music] And
so from there that's when I would enter
in at the close of this candlestick and
bet that we go down and then it will
theoretically if it plays out how you
want it'll start a downtrend. [music]
And so again this is another section of
that PDF. And then lastly, entering in
the trade, a few key things that are
very important is, again, we went over
this a little bit in the beginning,
stick to that 1:2, 1:3 riskreward ratio.
In the beginning, I suggest going for a
fixed riskreward ratio where you enter
in here, let's say, betting that the
market's going to go up and you're going
to take a profit at, let's say, this is
two times your risk. And so your [music]
risk would be down here. And so you
would, let's say, lose $100 if it went
all the way down here. And you would
make $200 if it gets all the way up
here. And you don't mess with it because
maybe you go break even. You move your
stop to break even to where you lose
zero on the trade as the market moves,
let's say, up here. But don't move your
profit target away. Try not to move your
stop too much because when you're
starting out, once you're in a trade,
there's a lot more emotions. And knowing
how to adjust and deal with that in real
time and read the market properly and
not have your emotions control you is
really hard. And it's likely that you,
you know, get out here early because
you're scared or nervous or greedy and
in reality the market was just having a
little bit of a pullback and then it's
going to keep going higher. And so I
highly suggest just sticking to a fixed
profit target and then over time adding
that flexibility in. Another huge
mistake a lot of beginners do is once
you have your stop loss, do not move it
further away. You're increasing your
risk on the trade, don't get married to
one specific trade because we have no
idea what the market is going to do. No
matter how perfect your entry looks, the
market could just do a little bit of
bounce and [music] just continue lower.
Do not increase your risk. Just take the
loss. Get used to losses. I have
something like a 40% win rate, 50% win
rate. But because I have that profitable
riskreward ratio that's in my favor, it
plays out in the long run. Same thing
with this is kind of going with those.
Plan your exits before you enter. Do not
jump in a trade and not know where
you're going to jump out with your
profit target or your stop-loss because
they're going to change when [music]
you're in the trade. You're going to
make different adjustments based on the
market and how your trade is going. And
instead, what you want to do is have a
plan before you enter the trade so you
can stick to that consistently. Okay. So
now I want to jump into some real
examples here so this can really be
solidified for you. I want to talk about
a couple of actually really important
factors for the strategy and entering
into these that I just forgot to talk
about. And then as well is go through
kind of these real examples because the
market's never the same. No trade is the
same, but these are really important to
help solidify and also to show you that
I'm looking for the exact same pattern
every day. That I really just sit here
and look for the same thing. It's
boring, but it works. And so to go
through that list, the first thing I do
every morning is I actually zoom out to
a 15-minute chart. Um the market opened
like up like this this morning where it
was um clearly we had a lot of
volatility the day before. And so what I
was looking at for here was the highs
here. Those are really far away, so
unlikely we're going to touch those. But
I was looking at, okay, here is the low
from yesterday. That's important to look
at. And if we get far enough down like
we I talked about earlier is that gap
was important to look at as well. And
then I just go into a smaller time frame
chart and essentially wait for the
market to open. And now a big key
actually is if I go back in this
recording is there's these two red lines
right here. And so what I've realized
over time is so I'm trading the S&P 500
futures and the NASDAQ futures. And so
[music]
they open up at 7:30 my time. And I've
realized that over time is that 15
minutes and 30 minutes after those
markets open are times where it's likely
to reverse. So today either it comes
down here and and hits and reverses or
it continues a bit lower or chops here
for a bit and then reverses at that 8:00
time which is 30 minutes. So technically
it would be 9:45 and 10:00 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time. And so and so that's
really those timings that I look for
every morning. And of course I need that
to align up with those other potential
factors we're looking at. And so today
what that was going into this was, you
know, we've already talked about this
downtrend a lot and then this flush
lower we had and then you can see it
started to slow down here. We had some
choppy candles and then we had a big
bullish candlestick and it starts to
come into that timing window at 15
minutes after the open where essentially
I'm what I'm looking for there is a
flush at the open and it to slow down
here and potentially reverse and that to
align up with factors that are showing
that the market will reverse [music] and
you know having this support zone here
and then having this downtrend was a
huge factor in that. And then the last
thing is going into looking for those
candlestick patterns to enter in on like
a double bottom or a head and shoulders
pattern. Now, this didn't have either of
those. What this had instead [music]
was a higher low where the market comes
down here, puts at a bottom, and then
makes a higher low and it continues
higher. And so, this is okay to enter in
sometimes because the market's moving so
quickly, and that's the only signal it
will give. Other times I like to wait
for a more cleaner double bottom
pullback. But in this case, I was
comfortable jumping in long on this as
it essentially broke this higher low
here. And so you can see I put in
essentially a buy stop order right here
above this high. Once it essentially
breaks this swing high here, I'm going
to get in on a long and I'm going to bet
to the upside. And [music] then my stop
is below this swing right here. And so
I'm risking about $1,500 on the trade.
And I'm looking for roughly about 2 or
3x. And so that's what, you know, I'd
like to see on the trade. But obviously,
as the trade plays out, I'm looking for
areas where it might slow down. But this
trade, you can see zooming through this
footage is it happened very, very
quickly. Is it I didn't really have any
pullbacks that went against me. It kind
of just shot up right away. And so in
that case, what I did is I elected to
get out pretty quickly. I was going to
get out at 4x my risk at with a limit
order if it went all the way up there.
But if it started to slow down at this
resistance zone I had drawn, I would
also just get out on a trailing stop.
And so there I essentially got out on
it, made a little bit of pullback, and I
got out right there for pretty much
$4,500 in pretty much 10 to 15 [music]
minutes. And so to show you another
example of this, just to show you how
repeatable this is, but also these are
trades I've taken where I've waited for
a couple of days, right? It's not
showing up perfectly every time, but
this is a perfect example again with a
couple of different nuances to it. And
so, first off, every day, you know, I
come in and okay, these are the levels
I'm looking for. There's a a big bottom
here with another higher low. And so my
thought is okay well if the market comes
down here I want to look for a bounce
[music] and also there's a little
resistance level here and so once I draw
those I go into you know a smaller time
frame chart I draw those red lines of
those keys where uh 15 minutes and 30
minutes after the open that I want to
see a reversal and then essentially as
it comes into that reversal timing just
like this last trade is what is the
volatility going into this and so on
this day. There's good movement. Again,
these are cherrypicked days in the sense
of I'm only taking trades on days where
it's good. You're not going to see
movement like this every day, but it's
there's no point in showing you, you
know, recordings of me just sitting
there not taking a trade, right? And so
those days I'm just sitting there and,
you know, I sit there for 30 minutes and
I move on with the day. But days like
this where there's clearly movement in
the market. And what I'm looking at is
right here. You can see I literally draw
it exactly how I want in the recording.
I'm trying to visualize, okay, we're in
a downtrend here. That downtrend has
broken with this trend shift right here
in this candlestick. What I want to see
is if we make a pullback here and then
that would signal essentially making a
higher low pattern which would then I
would like to enter in once it broke
this previous high and I would capture a
swing up ideally to the market open.
Huge thing about these swings and these
flush moves I've noticed is it pretty
much the easy money and the easy move is
when it reverses that move back. It has
a big move down here and then I just I
essentially want to just target this
move back. Now it could continue higher
and now that I'm a little more seasoned
with managing these trades, I can try
and hold on. But sometimes I'll just
close out because I think no, that's the
easy money. I don't think there's good
potential to continue higher reading the
big picture. That's where the experience
comes into play. But this is essentially
me being like, okay, that's what I'm
looking for today. And so it's hard
sitting and waiting through this move
because the feeling is, well, what if it
just shoots up and I miss it? That
happens. But I'm risking, you know, so
much money here that I don't need to be
in a trade very often. I could take one
of these a week and if I won every time
because of how patient I was for a good
setup, I would still be making like 20k
a month. And so trying to keep that in
mind to help me be patient is really
good. And so the market here, if we
watch this, it made a pullback here. And
so I'm planning that I'm going to put my
stop loss below this candlestick here if
it ends up being really bullish. And
then I'm going to enter in as it breaks
above this swing because again that's a
confirmation that it's making a higher
high. And so I I slightly missed it
there, but then I entered in and put an
order, jumped in essentially as it broke
that, put my stop loss where I had
planned, and I'm looking for two or 3x
in profit. And so essentially at that
point, I'm not going to go into managing
too much here, but I moved to break even
essentially once it got to the market
open where I see a potential for it to
reverse, but I didn't want to close out
there because I still like the potential
to go higher. And then from there, I
just managed with the swing and the
movement of the market eventually
getting out at about 2 1/2 times my risk
for about $4,500 again in pretty much 15
minutes. And then I just move on with my
day and I'm done trading. And so if you
want to dive deeper into the strategy, I
highly recommend watching this video on
futures and how they work. I find them
way more better to trade than any other
asset. And this will go into all the
nuts and bolts on how it works.